Hey there Wisconsinites.
Or Wisconsonians.
Wisconsin.
People who live in Wisconsin.
There, nailed it.
Conan O'Brien here, reminding
you that registering to vote
is as easy as hitting
Davante Adams in the flat
if you're Aaron Rodgers.
Or hitting the broad side of a barn,
if you're Jordan Love.
You Packers fans know exactly
what I'm talking about.
If you don't register to vote,
that would be like trading
up in the first round
of the NFL draft to take a
QB who is still years away
from being a viable starter,
even though you have
a future Hall of Famer
at the same position, who's still playing
at the top of his game, right?
Anyhow, democracy is a lot like poutine.
No matter how crispy the French fries are,
and no matter how savory the gravy,
democracy is only as delicious
as the cheese curds on top.
And in this metaphor,
the cheese curds are you,
the great voters of Wisconsin.
You are the cheese curds.
And if you want your
democracy to be delicious,
you will climb up on top
of those gravy smothered French fries.
Now you see in that scenario,
that's you voting in this metaphor.
You see, I hope that clears everything up.
You, the poutine, you get it.
Anyway, make sure to vote.
Remember Wisconsin, October 14th
Be the cheese curds.
I know you are, that you can be.